- OH, HERE WE GO,
WE GOT MORE.
HEY!
WHAT'S UP, TED AND ANNETTE?
COME ON IN.
YES. FANGS FOR COMING.
[laughs]
HAVE A BLOODY GOOD TIME.
AWESOME.
OH! OH.
- [sings like Michael Jackson]
♪ EE-HEE!
- THERE HE IS.
WHAT'S UP, NOAH?
- ♪ SHAM ON!
- MICHAEL JACKSON.
- ♪ [vocalizing]
- OH, HERE IT IS.
- ♪ HEE-HEE!
- YEAH, THAT'S WHAT HE DOES.
- THAT'S MICHAEL JACKSON.
- ♪ HEE-HEE!
- ALL RIGHT.
- ♪ HEE-EE HEE!
- GREAT!
- OW!
- NICE.
- ♪ HO!
♪ SHAM!
- OH, THERE WE GO.
- ♪ SHAM!
- THERE WE GO.
- ALL RIGHT, THREE'S THE CHARM.
- ♪ SHAM ON!
- FOUR.
- HA!
- ALL RIGHT, WELL--
- ♪ ANNIE, ARE YOU OKAY?
- OH! HE'S LEANING.
HE'S LEANING.
- ♪ ARE YOU OKAY, ANNIE?
- ALL RIGHT.
ARE YOU OKAY?
- ♪ ANNIE
♪ ARE YOU OKAY, ANNIE?
♪ YOU'VE BEEN TOUCHED BY
A SMOOTH CRIMINAL ♪
- VERY NICE.
- HA!
- OH, HERE WE GO.
- ♪ SHAMONE! HA!
- OH, MORE KICKS.
- HA! CLOSER! CLOSER!
- MORE KICKS. YOU'RE--
- CLOSE TO YOUR FACE!
- YOU--
AH! YOU ALMOST HIT ME THERE.
- ♪ [vocalizing]
- YOU'RE REALLY GETTING--
- ♪ SHAM ON!
- NO MORE SHAMONES.
- ♪ [vocalizing]
HOO HOO! ♪
- YOU WANT TO COME INSIDE?
- OH! HA! HA!
- THAT'S ANNOYING.
THAT IS VERY ANNOY--
STOP. STOP! J--
DON'T DO IT ANYMORE.
- HA!
♪ YO! SHAMONE!
- GREAT.
JUST KEEP DOING THE SHAMONE.
- OH!
- THAT'S THE ONE--
- ♪ WHERE THE CHILDREN AT?
♪ HEE! HEE!
- "WHERE THE CHILDREN AT?"
- ♪ JESUS JUICE! HO!
- THAT'S IN BAD TASTE.
THIS ISN'T--
- [growls]
- DON'T EVEN KNOW
WHAT THAT IS.
- THRILLER EYES.
♪ SHAMONE!
- WHAT--WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
- ♪ JAM IT ON!
JAM IT ON! ♪
- NO, YOU'RE CUT OFF
OF SHAMONES.
- I'M--OH, OKAY.
HA!
- YOU ARE--HE DOESN'T
SLAP HIS ASS LIKE THAT,
SO I DON'T KNOW WHAT--
OKAY.
- ♪ NAH-NAH-NAH,
NAH-NAH-NAH, NAH-NAH-NAH-NAH ♪
♪ NAH-NAH
- NO, HE DOESN'T--
I'VE NEVER SEEN HIM
HIT HIS ASS--
HEY. BUT NO--
- O-OH!
[prolonged yell]
- HEY--CAN WE JUST--HEY--
- [prolonged yell]
- HEY, MAN--
- HEY, STOP--STOP IT! STOP IT!
STOP IT!
THE [bleep] COSTUME'S
AWFUL,
THE IMPRESSION IS STUPID
AND PLAYED OUT,
EVERYBODY AND THEIR MOTHER
WAS MICHAEL JACKSON
THREE YEARS AGO
WHEN HE DIED!
- HE DIED?
- OH.
- WAIT--WAIT, HE DIED?
- OH, NOAH.
- [sighs]
- OH, NOAH--
- ♪ BOO HOO
- WHAT?
NO, WAIT--WAIT A SECOND.
DON'T SAD-MOONWALK AWAY.
- ♪ MM, BOO HOO
- YOU KNOW WHAT? LET--
- ♪ BOO HOO!
- HAPPY HALLOWEEN.